all right so jumping in um
if anyone if someone has actually never
seen or read anything that you've done
what is the first thing you want them
watching or reading and why
i i don't i don't know i want them to
think it's good
i i'd want them to think it's
distinctive i'd want them to think you
can tell it's by me
and i
certainly want them to uh
think that it's not
you know
many hands hollywood product or
something it was done by me
an individual human writer
i completely completely get it um
jumping into why i get actually one
other question if you could get the
financing to make anything you want
tomorrow what would you make and why
uh
well that's an interesting question
because
you know that that kind of is out there
if you actually
you know want to pursue it and do stuff
like that i think i'd do something um
probably historical
probably set in the regency era
whether it be something along the lines
of my tripoli which never got made
uh for various reasons or
uh another thing i had that was
set during the war of 1812 in the uh
in the pacific
ocean
and i i think it would be a big
thing like that sort of a
big robert balti david laney
sort of thing which is where i started
from which is where i came from
the thing is like uh
obviously with all the streamers that
are out there now they're all looking
for content and i'm sort of curious this
because i knew about tripoli i've known
you've wanted to make that for forever
is it something that you've actually
tried because i don't know who owns the
rights anymore is it something that
you've actually tried to repursue now
that all these streamers are looking for
you know the
content
no because at this point when you when
you think about it if i opened it right
now i'd have to completely rewrite it
you know it was good enough to take
everything by storm and get me into the
industry
then but if i read it now would i would
i like it would i want to change it
because
you know
mostly artists get worse
sometimes they get better right and i i
think i've had the luxury of getting a
little better as a writer and however
effective that script was
as a
you know
call it
a lawrence of arabia that really moved
you know is sort of a
you know sort of a
sort of a
david lean epic paced like a bond film
right
i mean it was it was good script it
worked but if i looked at it now i'd i'd
want to do it all over again i mean it'd
be like somebody uh
you know
looking at an old album they made
20 years ago
you know
you might not be able to stand it
you know who was this young punk who
wrote this
look at all the mistakes he made
or maybe not i might be surprised
um
the other thing i'd like to do is a uh
a western
sort of a black powder
western
and uh i've been messing around with
that
and uh
you know i i've been doing a little bit
of tv a lot of other things have a lot
of stuff in development i've i've
learned not to announce it
you know especially these days because
if you announce something all of a
sudden a preconception
gels and
calcifies about what it's going to be
you know and everybody predisposed to be
critical about stuff is pre-critical
about stuff and uh
you know you don't really have all that
much
room to move the mystery and the
sacredness
is gone
yeah i've spoken to a number of other
people that are more wary of saying
things until they're actually going um
but jumping into yeah it makes it worse
for people in the media
you know because you'd like to really
tell people what you're doing
you know i'd love to tell you what i'm
doing but i'd have to tell you off the
record these days
yeah because i i don't want people
banging off about something that's not
even
started yet you know
i've had these conversations with a
number of people that unfortunately are
off the record um jumping into why i get
to talk to you you are obviously
adapting this from a very very popular
book um and something that uh critically
claimed book um what is actually the
first steps when you are taking material
like that and deciphering it down to
what will make ultimately a two-hour
movie
well
first of all the uh
you know page count is the first thing
you know first of all do you love it do
you think you can do something with it
and the other thing is page count you
have to go from 500 odd pages to
115 or 120 pages
you know a page being a minute of film
and uh you you uh
have to start making
selections about what you're going to
use and what you
what you can't use
or i should say what you're going to
have to do without especially with such
a
beloved book beloved by me
also by the way
so um you know with that
what i've done with the last couple of
books i've adapted i've actually
um
flowed them in into text i can
manipulate
and i uh
i go through the text and i cut out what
i'm not going to use
i i'm not going to use that i'm not
going to use that i'm not going to use
that
retain
almost like you're hacking it out of
you know rock
you know if you're if you're sculpting
it and you end up
with what you need and all the time
you're making notes even if you cut
something out you you have it in your
head i'm gonna i'm gonna use this
so with the tender bar one of the things
was
if you look at it as the memoir it was
you would have to have three actors
playing jr
because there was a whole section when
he was a
young
adolescent
and teenager
and then there was the young man who's
going getting into yale and then there
was the boy who goes back to his
grandfather's house
and so the teenager unfortunately had to
go
you know
and uh
you had to make it work you had to join
those join those two parts have have the
the adolescence in there as sort of an
implied
thing you know
can you talk a little bit about
obviously once clooney gets involved i'm
sure he has notes on the script can you
sort of talk about how you guys worked
together to
ultimately get to what is on screen well
tell i'll tell you how we work together
i wrote the first draft about two weeks
later i heard he was doing it
okay and uh
then amazon greenlit
the first
draft and apart from a little bit of
voice over
we didn't do anything at all
he just went off and shot it
that's amazing
can you i mean for people
you know it's in the hand of hands of
professionals i mean look at the people
involved
you know they he he just saw that
he had a shooter
which he would you know
adjust to taste and necessity as he as
he went making
you know directorial choices and you
know he went off and did that and god
bless him for it
made it very easy
i was going to say for people that don't
understand the industry what you just
said is almost unheard of
yeah well they were ready for it george
and grant were ready for it because
they'd been trying to get it for get the
project since it was published
like 15 15 years ago and i think scott
rudin had it
and there may have been various attempts
to
uh
you know
get it together and they they never
happened as so often happens and then
somehow
the rights landed at amazon and amazon
ted hope at the time came to me
and asked me if i'd like to do it and i
said of course
and so grant and george who had been
trying to get the script for 15 years
were then notified that there was a
script
now
and they took a look at it
you know and i guess according to what
they say read it back and forth to each
other on the phone
and uh
don't let me characterize their process
though
um and decided to do it and here we are
one of the things that i found was uh uh
ben affleck as uncle charlie i felt like
he was almost chucky from goodwill
hunting like 25 years later you know
like there was almost a little bit of
that character in there um not you know
not on purpose just but it felt a little
like that did you notice that did you
feel that no i i didn't i think it's
coming from the from the background i
mean if there was some of that
you know i'd
i'd look to myself more than
more than i'd looked at him i mean
you know uncle charlie is a is a type of
tough
you know in charlie's case literate
which is not the case in the movie you
referenced
others is a tough literate
kind of
you know though their ethnicity is
unspecified you know
kind of literate
tough working-class
irish guy
and um
the uh
no i don't think so i mean i can see why
you'd see the sl see the slight
similarity but uh you know
i was gonna say i think it's that scene
with the psychologist
in the school where i felt a little bit
like i was but you know this is me
reaching
yeah no i don't i don't
i don't know i have to tell you i don't
i don't see it
it's tough no it's totally it's totally
you know as a type yes but i i think
it's a
i think he's being pretty
innovative in it you know if it's
reminiscent in a good way that's good no
it's reminiscent in a good way for me
i've it's yeah anyway let's let's switch
off that so um if i'm not mistaken neil
jordan is shooting marlow which uh
which you wrote um what can you tease
about that project because it sounds
[ __ ] cool sorry for my language
well it's it's uh
it's really cool it's neil jordan doing
it which is a good by me
and
you know and neil's like bill do you
mind if i write on it a little bit and
i'm like no you
you're neil [ __ ] jordan aren't you
you know so uh you know the answer the
answer is yes so uh
i i
really like him we met in ireland he's
he's off doing this in
uh spain
of all places barcelona spain
with liam neeson
and uh
and he had the genius idea
to do 1939
los angeles and barcelona
which still has the trolley tracks and
the old buildings and its own relics of
spanish colonial architecture
and looks a little
otherworldly in the way that
la would have been at the time
and
also when you get out into the fringes
what would have been the west side in
l.a
i mean it was all
you know uh
after it became irrigated it became all
jungly
hillsides and things like that so
you know
that area of spain
uh
looks
really interestingly
like
the los angeles of the of the 1930s
for people that aren't familiar with the
story uh what can you tease them about
it
uh well it's
philip marlowe raymond chandler's philip
marlow obviously
um but it's not from a
chandler book it's from the continuation
of the chandler books
uh by the irish novelist
john benville
a brilliant brilliant
novelist
who does these books under the
under the pen name benjamin black
so
john benville is one of the world's
greatest novelists
and you've got one of the world's
greatest novelists doing a raymond
chandler book
you know
i went for that immediately
and uh it's from a book called the
black-eyed blonde
and i called it
simply marlow
in the hope of the series
i mean if you can imagine
liam neeson is philip marlow i can't
you know it's one of those things that
just hasn't happened before
yeah
you guys did it now the governor's here
right
um i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
as as always uh my time is up as always
it is awesome to talk with you and see
you hopefully next time in person and
check your email
all right i will
you